but as for joe biden he was not on the
campaign trail yesterday instead he was
in delaware preparing for tonight when
the presidential candidates
will face off in their final debate in
nashville now their microphones
will be muted at times that is a change
and this may be
a critical moment overall as president
trump trails joe biden nationwide
and in key swing states like
pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
we are joined now by cbs news political
analyst rice
reince priebus president trump's former
chief of staff
and former senior adviser to president
obama valerie jarrett good morning to
both of you
reince i want to begin with you the
president appears to be
trailing in the polls even if the polls
were as wrong as they were in 2016 he
appears to be trailing
so the question is first off do you
believe the president has some ground to
make up
and if so how does he do it if so
well thanks for having me well there's
always room to make up ground right no
matter where you're at even if you're a
little ahead or a little behind
i think number one if you do look at
those polls
they're really not that much different
tony than they were four years ago
i mean the averages are pretty close to
the same and if you look at the day
before
the election in 2016 they're not that
far
off everyone was writing off donald
trump in 2016. he pulled it off
well how does he do it number one let
biden talk let him explain his positions
on the supreme court packing on isis on
the iran deal
you know what happened in regard to
terrorism around the world under his
watch
what's his position on taxes he says he
wants to increase taxes uh he wants to
increase taxes on small businesses which
employ over 95 percent of the people
what's his position on energy he said he
was for the green new deal now he says
he's not
he says he was against fracking for
fracking now he's uh
assuming he was against fracking now
he's forfeiting can't keep track of it
the last thing i'd say to the president
just have fun be happy let biden talk
let him explain away
we'll see if that version of president
trump comes to debate tonight valerie
similar question to you we just heard
ryan say that the president should let
joe biden talk we expect
fewer interruptions tonight because
microphones will be muted during the
opening comments but open talking time
can be its own kind of hazard anyone who
spends their life on tv will know that
so what does joe biden do to avoid a
pitfall
and make some gains oh i don't think
he's worried about any pitfalls he's
looking forward to having an opportunity
to speak directly to the american people
about what he's going to do
to bring us back from this horrific code
covet 19
pandemic and also to build back our
economy and make sure that nobody gets
left behind
he is not going to raise taxes on anyone
who makes less than 400 000
he intends to help small businesses grow
and he intends to follow the science
and he's going to do it with a tone of
inclusion i love it when he says look
i'm running as a democrat but i'm going
to be the president for all of america
i think that's refreshing right word on
the street
unconfirmed reports is that you've been
working with the president
to prep him for tonight's debate is is
that true
i mean that's not true i'm certainly
talking to the president quite a bit
and the team and you know the whole
group of us you know the
2016 crew the 2020 crew we've all come
together and
doing everything we can to help the
president the senators
and our party win and have a good the
best year that we can
i i do think it's going to be close and
if you look at early vote
uh you look at absentee ballot voting
and it's actually a lot closer than
people realize especially with rural
america voting
in staggering numbers the president won
by about 18 percent in rural america uh
four years ago
that number's up by 28 percent it'll be
interesting how suburban america and
rural america come together and what
that looks like on election night
uh valerie i think reince brings up a
really good point 40 million people it
says have already voted so far
the record turnout numbers what does
that say to you
what i what that says to me is that
there's a lot of enthusiasm
uh for this race and i think for joe
biden we're also seeing big numbers in
our cities across the country
unfortunately gail long lines and i
think that's atrocious that the united
states can't pull off an election
without that but i do agree with ransom
it tends to
tighten at the end which is why i would
say to everyone out there if you see
that joe biden is leading in the polls
please don't have that give you a sense
of complacency that makes you stay at
home
make a plan go out and vote and vote
early if you can so that you aren't
stuck
waiting on election day in really really
long lines and for our safety
take the reasonable precautions as well
we're a mask
social distance president obama as you
know valerie hit the road last night he
as they say held nothing back
so i'm wondering for you when you
watched him speak so candidly it was
very clear
he had a very clear message they say
it's unprecedented to see him speak that
way
is it personal for him or do you think
he's mostly concerned about the country
what's his thinking
oh it's totally about the country gail
he is so
frustrated with the way the trump
administration has dropped the ball
in terms of how they handle this coveted
19
the rhetoric and the tone and the
policies the lack of acknowledgement
that we have racial healing that has to
be done
in this country the way that he does not
take an inclusive view
of our country and the messages that
we've sent around the world
people used to look at the united states
as a beacon of hope and now
they're just scratching their heads at
best and so i think
you know he enjoyed it you could tell he
was having a good time out there and as
the race closes down he wanted to go
back to pennsylvania
a state that he won twice with the help
of joe biden who's of course from
scranton
so i think it was a powerful message it
was an honest message
and it was a wake-up call to everyone
who's still not sure they want to vote
all right reince you're predicting a
good debate for president trump tonight
a different trump i think if you look
back at the town hall that president
trump
did with savannah guthrie last week
and he handled a pretty tough interview
very very well
i think you got high marks on that i
think you're going to see that same
president trump show up tonight all
right we will be watching
i know you guys too we'll see you
tonight valerie jarrett and reince
priebus
thank you guys for taking the time this
morning our live prime time coverage of
the final presidential debate starts
tonight at nine
eastern time six o'clock pacific right
here on cbs